- I don't like anyone listening
to the songs I write.
- Ever?
- They're for me.
- In one word, who are you?
- Only one word?
- Mm-hmm.
- Hmm.
- Mess.
Bess the mess.
Not the whole picture.
♪ I don't know what it is ♪
- My dad raised us
after my mom left.
♪ What it is about me ♪
But I have no safety net.
♪ I don't know how
to get where I'm going ♪
♪ I keep showing up
wherever I've already been ♪
I've got rent,
my brother's Medicaid co-pay.
- Bess, there are
82 words in your new song.
The average song is 165 words.
- Exactly. That's why
I need to go home and finish it.
- Why do you write songs
for no one to listen to?
- I tried. It didn't go over.
I'm sorry.
- I think that takes guts.
♪ Opening my eyes ♪
♪ To daylight... ♪
- When you sing,
your soul is all over your face.
♪ Maybe I will wander ♪
- We should play together some time.
♪ Too far away
from where I started ♪
♪ There is another ♪
- I watched you push away one dude
who seems to really like you...
and not this other dude
who's living with his girlfriend.
♪ Do you know? ♪
- Bess, this is Lina.
- I can't do this right now.
♪ What you fight for? ♪
♪ I want more ♪
- Who am I to--
- Do what your father couldn't do?
You playing small isn't
going to make him bigger.
♪ There is another ♪
- My dad always said...
sometimes you just gotta do it
for the love of it.
♪ Do you know ♪
♪ What you fight for? ♪
♪ I want more ♪